о.в.
на ранок після артобстрел під Маріуполем
вже
створюють враження наче хочуть захопити
це стратегічно важливе місто на березі
Азовського моря чергове ескалація
бойових дій на Донбасі не стала
несподіванкою Мінські угоди до цього
систематично порушувались а
співробітники спеціальної моніторингової
місії ОБСЄ протягом останніх днів
зафіксували значне збільшення обстрілів
інтерв'ю де в заступник голови місті
Олександрії зазначив що режим припинення
вогню нині не виконуються з обох боків
стягуються війська до лінії зіткнення
мирний процес під загрозою
ми бачимо значне зростання напруги в
регіоні Якщо ця тенденція триватиме то
буде дуже важко казати про відведення
важких озброєння оскільки відведення
зброї підрозділами неможливе у Брюсселі
засудила ескалацію військових дій на
Донбасі Вашингтон поклав
відповідальність за загострення ситуації
на проросійських сепаратистів Москва щоб
звинувачує Київ табор у повторення
запеклих боїв серпня Минулого року в
Україні вважають що Кремль намагається
створити передумови для наступу на
Донбасі у